as long as you don't blunder  everything in one move which is what he  did here  yeah it's it's clear that uh basically  he opted for this whole e4 business  basically based on this kind of  hallucination yeah  because  i think he was planning to to meet h5  with 92 yeah that's that's the big  problem  even though he actually spent 17 minutes  on this move  wow he just just shows that yeah he was  probably  deeply involved with  all kinds of compensation positions  right  trying to assess what happens after  knight takes you to queen bishop takes a  tool let's say queen g6 and you know he  spent tons and tons of time figuring  this out and then  yeah it's going to be a kind of a bad  feeling for him after the game because  yeah in particular if like in a  classical game you make a move not like  92 after 17 17 minutes of thinking and  your opponent comes back to the board  and just kind of looks at you strangely  and takes on g2 and you have to shake  his hand  it's not fun